bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj non ci siamo sud e
floris gelli favi gelli leggermente
strano come gioco cioè ve lo dico perché
non è altro è strano che non ci sia un
mezzo rumore nel menù non si sente un
caso sembra che sia un gioco molto
fantastico magari non c'è veramente un
cazzo di sogno e sto facendo una figura
di merda ma chi se ne frega ragazzi
proviamo a me e spunta è spuntato un
cereale g con gli anellini che ci sono
che devo fare
lo prenderei pali che cazzo e su ciò che
figo cena io io prendo dei pallini ed
esplode sta roba fantastico è una figata
pace così ci sta creando ragazzi oh mio
dio segreto fuori già [ __ ] che figata
mi se
no ma che figurano certamente un bel mea
di vento ragazzi devo sono io sono sono
questo sono un preservativo con due
gambe
devo capire un attimo ancora come come
si gioca non sta roba tra il cazzo il
fatto a società a entrare nelle finestre
perfetta la devo a così si torna
indietro fant hanno la meglio io già lo
amo credete cioè una figata pazzesca ma
intendevo devo entrare nelle finestre a
caso cioè devo andare tipo ok allora in
africa che al mio amor cina che cosa sta
facendo lega ma perché a parte regazzi
gli alberi che saltano in sto modo vice
di quello che sembra realmente se devo
essere sincero però ok il nome divenne
dico occhi e perfetto rea ci ho preso la
mano
manco per il cazzo carica nascita e
posso strisciare sui che figo alla
madonna che cazzo ho fatto un sa
benissimo perché c'è una una rana che sa
cos'è la bella renzi organista è ora che
io salto in alto e su cacia voglio
capire ma chi è che mi ha consigliato
sta roba che come ha fatto con noi come
si fa
un gioco così ramin attimo questa cosa
sta diventando abbastanza ok no
la faccio eccolo ok sembra che cosa ho
appena fatto troppo però ragazzi troppo
proprio impossibile di quello che è
sempre porca [ __ ]
sì sì sì ok io non ho ancora capito
quando non ancora capito no non ho
ancora capito no al morta con prima non
saltava un cazzo ne so un chilometro
fantastico posso rimbalzare sui muri
tipo prince of persia nomi che
bellissimo ok ok
si no ma perché sono tornato indietro io
sono ragazzi la demenza nel cervello
stando calmi ok ok perfetto nella calma
a risolvere tutto la calamita scusata
dalla fatina della rocca e no no no no
anzi per noi è chiaro è che perfetto
ragazzi mi hanno insegnato che con la
rabbia non si risolve un cazzo cazzate
ok forse no che sia e vabbè ma di lui
che a caso cosa insolita unisca lascerei
da ridere come si muovono gli alberi e
bellissimo devo passare di qua tipo me
cosa faccia passare tipo e non posso
avrà pieno se si è stato bellissimo dal
trovato rimbalzando lì continua su degli
alberi che mi saranno tipo di ando ma va
beh io io veramente si giochi ragazzi li
amo perché lo faccio a prenderlo questo
devo andare di stato no eh vabbè se
nella roba aggiungo quest'anno spiegate
cedevo no no è impossibile corsa che
apre forse non sono sì con sé un genio
non ci avevo pensato ali ok qua devo
tipo star tranquillo che se non mimì
stuprano si ok ok no perché se fa essere
più deficiente ma si può non la cosa
bella di sto gioco e che non mi fa
incazzare perché sennò mi fa incazzare
perché tipo c'è la musichetta troppo
dolce quindi è difficile che mi incazzi
se riesco a fare un salto al mio ok ok
perfetto sta diventando strano come
faccio a fare questa solidea rega ciò
l'idea cioè l'idea
no proprio un cazzo proprio zero e
volevo passarvi sottomano mirino ma come
cazzo ho fatto non lo so non lo so ma va
bene così no è una figata
basta basta no no no no no no no no no
perché c'è una porta stavolta sì sì l'ho
presa lo prendo ventre qua dentro
perfetto el'assessore bellissimo
bellissimo ragazzo ha passati poi il
primo livello era livello 1 questo che
prima di farvi stuprare la delle rane a
caso vediamo di andare avanti perché a
poverina quella che è stata sola devoti
può si può liberare non mi dispiace ecco
[ __ ] allora devo farmi cazzi miei
perché fanno i cazzi degli altri muoio
fatemi andare via perché ok non ho
capito le rane ragazzi mele dovete
spiegare perché non le ho capite in sto
gioco però va bene voglio fare amicizia
con una rana di merda sola perché non è
possibile giorno che andrebbe tipo di
essere mia amica stiamo insieme tutto te
e allora sei stronzo
ascoltateli e vabbè sono caduto io ho
capito che sono impedito a sto gioco di
qua non salve mi sa dire per caso la
strada hanno anche lei e [ __ ]
perfetto dove sto andando ragazzi non ho
capito dove sto andando ragazzi sto
gioco uno dei concerti più belli che
abbia mai giocato perché l'altro il
sensore perfetto pianta bellamia vuoi
venire per con me per caso di olio ai
biscotti brava zia vedeva dirti che i
biscotti si risolve tu non l'hai è
andata ciò ibisco vieni qua perfetto mi
ha seguito mi ha seguito nell'ascesa no
no io la vado a riprendere la vado a
riprendere perché mi sono innamorato di
stara e ha lasciato aveva affanculo è
non è per essere stronzi ma prossimo
piatto ragazzi cosce di rado valeeva in
altra parte
no no io allora ragazzi se io riuscissi
a saltare prima di niente niente una
sega che merda o mischia chiusa è un
trampolino sto coso se riuscisse a
centrarlo magari è stato è stato figo
tra l'altro sono bellissimi non so che
cosa
ragazzi io non so che cosa sono ma li
voglio adesso mi sono innamorato di sti
cosi a caso se non tornassi indietro
ogni 4 po tutti i secondi magari faremo
un metro perfetto secondo me la mia
teoria di sto giochi che il protagonista
è andato in
perché non ci crea funzionando di brutto
st teoria se tipo un passaggio laggiù
per raggiungerlo è leggermente un casinò
a meno che non è ok perfetto ma
intendevo girare i livelli adesso non mi
chiama figata è il gioco più strano che
abbia mai fatto nella storia perché non
so perché maggio festa roma viene una
voglia di gelatina improvvisa a caso
ragazzi il prossimo episodio ogni volta
che è che che cade un assaggio di budino
che è una cosa strana è sto gioco io ve
lo dico ragazzo non ho mai veramente non
è giocato un gioco così porca sua
sorella in pià strata di gelatina non si
può fare su ok
sì cioè non farlo non so come ho fatto
ma se muoiono lo rifarò mai più ok
ragazzi stop no no no no io mi sto
pagando io vi dico che se muoio non lo
rifaccio più sì sì se ragazzi no si no
io ci ho paura
si pregano la riforma io se muoio non li
faccio più non lo rifaccio che si no si
no i due ragazzi sono non fa non so non
so come sia possibile ma sono vivo e
ringrazio dio per fare un pezzo solo e
magari con l'ascensore e stacco perché
io devo tornare devo tornare indietro
sono non sono contento calmi calmi
no sì eccolo ecco che sto facendo a caso
piano ok perfetto adesso di nuovo di
nuovo di modi nuove di voi che cadono
che cadono che cadono che cade allora
perché l'ho fatto se lo sapevo perché
sono un [ __ ] spingi spingi valido
per preservativo che non sembra lo zio
bra
mio zio è stato tracce l'ho fatta massa
così fa diventando treno tipo il
cappellino da panda che mi stringe il
cervello e non capisco pure sono io come
facciamo andare su di preciso
devo andare di qua come faccio mandare
su no
i beni sono ragazzi che la musichetta ti
dà armonia pensieri puri e dolcezza
melandri che ha creato sto gioco del
calcio per non morire tutti insanguinati
dalla testa ai piedi vapore ascolta
albero led niente bello di sta minkia
guarda che ho sbagliato anche
girare [ __ ] che deve morire era
era giusto devo fare così praticamente
vabbè ma certo tipo gira adesso devo
rigirarlo di nuovo tipo se devo fare
così no
ecco così così dovrei credo che no credo
che un cazzo ci sono ci sono ci sono sì
sì mio dio è stato è stato atroce
ragazzino non ne posso fatemi arrivare
all'ascensore niente non ci arriverò mai
niente ho trovato il livello giusto per
me perché il suo livello ci vuole ci
vuole mira cioè devo centrare i fiori
diventerò vecchio ios no non ce la farò
mai regala impossibile
dovrai so l'ho preso l'ho preso
ma basta farsi grazie alle grazie ha
definito si sa è stato è stato
fanta ma questo non era all'inizio si fa
ok ok praga sono arrivato all'ascensore
basta basta non ne posso basta che si è
aggiunto ho aggiunto un pallino lì che
figo dopo per il piace praticamente
ragazzino mettere tutti i pallini al
posto giusto per per sbloccare sta roba
fantastico d'accordo ragazzine che posso
concludere qui perché tanto non è cioè
ci metterò gli anni a farli tutti
praticamente e c'è la rana di prima
bastard e allora vedi che esistono
continuerò ragazzine se vi piace perché
è un po diverso da tutti i giochi che ho
fatto di solito quindi potrebbe non
piacervi
lo capisco però ci ho provato ma devi
sapere se volete che lo con tv ragazzi
comunque è servito è piaciuto ha
lasciato sgomento mi piace anche ai
fagiani facebook e come noi video
trovate la descrizione cioè se dovresti
desideri ci vediamo un proprio video
belle ragazze
[Musica]